do you remember the first ever time he
truly felt a connection to something in
an anime was it a whole show a character
a scene or perhaps it was just the
single line one moment I remember
vividly was when my grandmother passed
away it was the first time in my life I
really had to grieve and there were so
many emotions I didn't quite know how to
process it all it was then a few months
later that I got to see some awards for
the first time and it was only then that
it truly hit me seeing the way this
enormous family functioned together
laughed together cry together under the
caring watch of a loving grandma with
such an eerie reflection of my family
that I held dear it resonated with me so
deeply that it actually brought out the
emotions I didn't quite know how to
process before that was the moment for
me the moment when you weren't just
watching someone else's story on screen
you were living it he had lived it you
wanted to live it part of it resonated
with a fiber of your being and for a
moment you felt a personal connection
not to some person for something
intangible that you were watching after
I felt that for the first time anime
sees being something that could just
entertain me but something that could
also connect with me on an unspoken
level that no person had ever done
before well got me thinking about this
recently was when I got to see a silent
voice in cinemas which I absolutely
adored it's rare to see something that
feels so intimate and familiar yet
tackling very difficult issues in such a
grounded and personal fashion suicide
social anxiety bullying disabilities
depression none of these are played as
anything overly dark dramatic or tragic
it's just portrayed as real which they
are
as while touching on these tough themes
it manages to convey some of the most
tender hearts warming moments in life
you get from finding the close
friendship and reconnecting with people
from your past because that's just the
way life is
some days are fine some days are not and
there's no on/off switch for these kinds
of things you don't have to experience a
tragic loss to feel like your world is
falling apart
you don't have to be in the middle of an
epic story to feel like life is crashing
at your feet sometimes you wear a mask
because you're not ready to let the
world know that you're not doing okay
and the people in your life you can seem
the most fine I sometimes the furthest
thing from it it was such a raw delicate
depiction of the most joyful and
cruelest moments a person can go through
and the amazing thing I felt while
watching this film is that you realize
the smallest tragedies can come if you
just let life play itself out seeing
something like this always leaves me
feeling warm even if the topics explored
weren't exactly Pleasant it's like a
cathartic realization and someone else
out there gets it gets you and it
doesn't have to be any big emotional
moment sometimes it's just a mood an
atmosphere that has a familiar scent to
it I left the movie with this heartfelt
nostalgic feeling like coming home after
a long trip and tasting mom's home
cooking for the first time in forever
[Music]
it's this feeling this connection that I
managed to experience more so in animes
and I do anywhere else and it's not just
the shows or movies that come out but
also the people surrounding it I can't
tell you the amount of times I've met a
person in this community he deals with
similar issues that these characters
have to live with on a daily basis no
it's not always dramatic and no it's not
always the people you think it's going
to be but it is always so very real and
you'd be surprised how a medium can
attract so many people similar issues
thought processes and experiences
growing up that goes beyond just a
general interests of animation that
comes from Japan it's like there is
something quite different about anime
that's hard to put into words but its
appeal managed to attract certain people
and while I can't put down exactly what
this is in a few sentences I will say
that no matter how different our tastes
are or varied we are as people in order
to like and appreciate some of the stuff
we see coming out of this medium we all
have to be at least a little bit weird
whatever that means if someone were to
ask me what my ultimate goals are with
the videos I put out people may think
it's to entertain or to be funny but in
all honesty is to connect connect for
the friends connect with a stranger
connect with someone I know connect with
someone I want to know connect with all
sorts of people from all walks of life
in places I would never be able to reach
in my lifetime connect with you and
sometimes even connect with myself
because that's the biggest thing that
draws me to anime of course when I talk
about connection it's not always
something you can relate to a series can
just as easily speak to the person you
want to be rather than the person you
are now
put thoughts you've had on screen like
you've never quite vocalize correctly or
taken a subject and made you think about
it in a totally different light how many
people have related to the mental
anguish of the Evangelion task how many
have been inspired by Simone's actions
on his hero's journey or gotten lost in
the world of a Ghibli film
[Music]
the worst thing is if we were to admit
how intimately we hold some of these
moments some people's first reaction
would be to ridicule like being real as
a weakness that makes you an easy
targets how stupid is it for these dumb
cartoons to actually have a personal
effect on our lives how sad and detached
from reality we must be but that's just
it some of us wanted that brief break
from reality and there's nothing wrong
in that
we built walls to protect ourselves from
getting hurt
shut the gate and threw away the key
because it's safer to stay closed
protected from the cruel words of a
fellow human being but that's why it was
easier to connect to a story or a
character or an idea even if it's cheesy
and childlike I always thought it was
embarrassing when I looked back at my
teenage self connected to a character
like Naruto in a simple adolescence when
I could cheer for the underdog because
we saw ourselves as the quiet underdog
but now it's not just a character who
was there when I was a kid but a
character I've actually grown up with
and as we grew older and learned that
the world wasn't just a simple battle of
good and evil geniuses versus hard
workers
I never stopped yearning for this same
connection I felt the kid the more
people I've met in this community the
more I realized that we've all found
something that resonated on a deep
personal level and in doing so it's
given us an opportunity to connect with
each other which I couldn't be more
thankful for now but I found the friends
I never did in my teenage years when
these animations were my closest
connection we complain and joke about
the common trends in cliche we see all
the time but if you stop and think about
it this is one of the most varied
mediums out there which is why anyone
explores it enough they are sure to find
something that speaks for them there are
the grand epic stories and bombastic
gripping shows that grab the spotlight
but there are also very personal tales
and crazy artistic ideas being thrown
around I mean where else you say in one
season you could be watching a show
about gay ice skaters our historic royal
battle which is in World War two but
wrestling and a down to earth drama
about dictionary
ha
it's not always about right from the
perfect story or getting critical
recognition everything has his own voice
its own story to tell which could easily
say something to you because it's easy
to scare they're behind the screen
behind every screen isn't a callous
machine producing stories producing
animation producing content but it's a
person someone with their own thoughts
ideas and emotions they want to express
like you like me
so look if I had to sum up whatever
points I was trying to make we all go
through this strange love-hate
relationship with anime as fans but
beyond that anime hasn't only been there
as entertainment it's given me the
friends I could never find growing up
kept me company when I needed a
distraction from life gotten me through
some of my hardest times resonated with
all sorts of aspects of myself brought a
community together that I genuinely
loved and it continually gives me the
chance to meet and connect with new and
amazing people that I never would have
met otherwise and when I think about it
like that it's quite amazing really and
I hope to god it's done something
similar for you too as you shouldn't be
ashamed to admit that because for me at
least that really is
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]